llegamos aquí
[Música]
muy buenos días con todos
y hoy les quiero hablar sobre algún
concepto un tanto distinto complejo que
es el bienestar financiero y más que
hablarles sobre esto quiero compartirles
mi experiencia y acercarles un poco más
a este concepto tan importante para
nuestras vidas piensen por un momento
que es el bienestar financiero para mí
esta es una gran imagen de lo que denota
[Música]
visualizó como bienestar financiero y
básicamente al ser un concepto complejo
tenemos que irlo desglosando y tomar
algunos puntos necesarios para que
ustedes lo puedan alcanzar ok el primero
es que el bienestar financiero no está
en un ente externo no es el dinero no
son los activos no son muchas variables
que tenemos en nuestra cabeza el
bienestar financiero inicia y parte en
nosotros y por eso lo primero que quiero
mencionar acá es la práctica activa del
mindfulness el mindfulness es una
ciencia ya que tiene mucha antigüedad y
que para el mundo occidental fue
introducir apuntó cóncava chin en las
principales universidades del mundo y a
través de la meditación empezamos a
entender el por qué y principalmente el
para qué de las cosas
tenemos que estar conscientes que
nosotros tenemos diariamente entre
cuatro mil y siete mil pensamientos que
atraviesan nuestra cabeza y controlar
eso es una tarea muy complicada para la
cual tenemos que prepararnos y dentro de
estos la gran mayoría son impulsos de
marketing salió un auto nuevo salió un
iphone nuevo n variables que nos inducen
a la compra no productiva ok lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es seguir un poco
un poco el concepto he hecho un pequeño
proceso sobre mindfulness que quiero
compartir con ustedes
el paso número uno es tomar conciencia
tomar conciencia nos hace que nos
queramos más que nos cuidemos más y que
empecemos a estar bien si vemos la
palabra bienestar y le damos la vuelta
es de estar bien se entiende mucho más
fácil así una vez que nosotros estamos
bien está comprobado que trabajamos
mejor nuestra productividad incrementa
hasta en un 45% somos mucho más
efectivos y esto también a su vez genera
que mejoren las relaciones humanas
nuestras relaciones interpersonales
fluye y finalmente con esto tomamos
mejores decisiones y por qué es
importante llegar a este punto las
finanzas personales son decisiones de
cada día de nada sirve que yo hago un
plan trabajé muchos años por él y de un
momento a otro tomo una decisión que me
lleve o me re traiga o me lleve para
atrás cinco años en ese plan
tenemos que trabajar nuestras finanzas
personales a diario ok y para eso el
principal punto somos nosotros el eje de
nuestro ser
ok hace algunos años es fundado una
compañía con algunos socios y tengo la
oportunidad de asesorar a diario a
muchas personas que están buscando
construir bienestar financiero que están
buscando mejorar su situación económica
que están buscando construir más
patrimonio n variables y la pregunta
común que siempre me hacen es ok cuál es
la fórmula para el bienestar financiero
y quiero compartir con ustedes estos
años de asesoría y estas conversaciones
muy muy atractivas que me han llevado a
proponer esta fórmula para el bienestar
financiero antes de antes de mostrar la
fórmula quiero invitarles a que ustedes
empiecen a planificar al revés de como
normalmente hacemos lo más importante
para el bienestar financiero es tener un
plan
pero el error está en que nosotros
tenemos un plan y empezamos a diario a
tomar acciones nosotros tenemos que
visualizar nos en ese plan a cinco años
en cinco años quiero llegarás a este
punto que tengo que hacer hoy día para
acercarme a ese plan tenemos que empezar
a planificar al revés ok cuál es la
famosa fórmula del bienestar financiero
educación más ahorro por tiempo voy a
desglosar cada una de las variables para
que se entienda mejor y estas variables
se conectan la una va en secuencia a la
otra lo primero que tenemos que
reconocer es que durante nuestras vidas
jamás hemos recibido una clase de
finanzas personales
hemos aprendido muchas cosas en la
escuela en el colegio en la universidad
en las maestrías en los posgrados
siempre recibimos información pero
lamentablemente no recibimos información
que nos ayude a gestionar mejor nuestra
relación con el dinero muchas personas
tienen en la cabeza el concepto que el
dinero es malo el dinero no es malo lo
que es malo es lo que nosotros hacemos o
dejamos de hacer con el dinero tenemos
que mejorar esa relación el dinero es
muy positivo para nuestras vidas porque
simplemente nos permite ayudar nos
permite ser parte de la solución de un
problema que tiene américa latina' que
es la riqueza ok
al tener tan poca educación tenemos que
auto educarnos y no hay nada más
maravilloso que la lectura les invito a
ustedes que lean cuatro libros al año
una tarea sencilla pero que nos va a
aportar muchísimo a mejorar nuestro
coeficiente financiero
me imagino que muchos de acá han leído
el libro padre rico padre pobre es un
gran punto de inicio ya quienes no lo
han hecho les invito a que lo hagan es
un gran punto de inicio más encontrar
estrategias y herramientas es un libro
que nos ayuda a tener una visión
distinta de lo que se puede hacer si que
nos motiva a construir esta relación
positiva con el dinero hay libros un
poco más avanzados como piensa y hágase
rico de napoleón hill un libro que nos
implanta el ferviente poder del deseo
básicamente tenemos que poder vivir
nuevas experiencias
esto es práctica no es teoría todo lo
que veamos en los libros tenemos que
llevar a la práctica no podemos dejar el
conocimiento puro en la charla anterior
nos hablaban de conocimiento y
experiencia lo que realmente lo que
realmente vale es la experiencia ok y
algo fundamental
tenemos que mejorar nuestras habilidades
numéricas esta es una de las grandes
desafíos que tenemos que auto educarnos
para que para que el momento que
abordemos una situación real de vida
hagamos los cuatro ejes que están ahí
creemos nuestro propio camino y
perseveramos nos visualizamos como
ganadores esa confianza que me da el
tener el conocimiento me permite dar un
paso más que es muy necesario para el
éxito que dará oportunidad de ser
apasionado de eso se trata la vida de
crear oportunidades en todo hay
oportunidades tenemos que empezar a
pensar de otra forma para encontrarlas y
finalmente utilizar todos los recursos
nosotros tenemos contacto de relaciones
amistades conocimientos y todo eso
aporta en nuestro bienestar financiero
ok una vez que hemos avanzado en este
proceso y que la educación está a
nuestro favor la segunda variable
importante para el bienestar financiero
es del ahorro pero más allá del ahorro
que tenemos en mente de dejarnos poner
en la cuenta bancaria esto se trata de
hacer un ahorro activo si normalmente
empezaban las personas empiezan con
cuentas bancarias cuentas de ahorros y
ponemos el dinero ahí pero a través de
la educación tenemos que ir
evolucionando nuestros ahorros pasar a
inversiones hay instrumentos financieros
mucho más
eficientes que nos permiten construir
riqueza donde el rendimiento financiero
no va a ser uno o dos puntos
probablemente estemos en un 78 16 por
ciento si hacemos inversiones de la
bolsa de valores emprendimientos no hay
nada que además promete un buen
emprendimiento y por eso es importante
hacerlo y estos emprendimientos se
convierten en negocios tenemos que
empezar a visualizar esto porque es
parte de nuestro bienestar de nuestra
tranquilidad de nuestra estabilidad
emocional ok
algo importante y algo que siempre
discutimos con nuestros clientes es la
importancia de pagarse primero a
nosotros mismos es fundamental y
normalmente el patrón que tenemos de
gastos es completamente al puesto
opuesto al que deberíamos tener las
personas normalmente cuando recibimos
dinero gastamos en primer lugar
pagamos cuentas y si nos sobra dinero
ahorramos y ese patrón tiene que cambiar
completamente tenemos que empezar por
ahorrar luego pagamos las cuentas y si
nos sobra el dinero gastemos esto nos va
a construir mucho bienestar a largo
plazo
algo fundamental y tomando la tercera
variable y metiéndole a esta ecuación es
el tiempo nosotros tenemos que dejar de
ver las cosas a corto plazo siempre
queremos que todo sea inmediato
que todo sea para mañana y en el mundo
real del dinero y de las inversiones eso
no funciona
eso se llama especulación y no construye
riqueza tenemos que empezar a pensar a
largo plazo ok que pasa cuando nosotros
utilizamos el interés compuesto el
interés compuesto según albert einstein
es la octava maravilla del mundo
albert einstein decía que la fuerza más
poderosa que mueve el universo es el
interés compuesto un tipo tan ingente
tan inteligente como él llegó a estas
conclusiones y porque después de que un
par de ejemplos para que ustedes
visualicen de mejor manera la
importancia del tiempo que pasa si
nosotros decidimos ahorrar cinco dólares
diarios el auditorio súper joven veo que
la mayor cantidad de personas tienen
aquí menos de 25 años o están por esa
edad y me encanta porque si ustedes
deciden a partir de hoy empezar a
ahorrar cinco dólares diarios y lo
ponemos en un instrumento que nos paguen
7.5 que no es bajo tampoco es alto es
una tasa de interés promedio y tenemos
este buen hábito durante 40 años ustedes
van a llegar a tener 400 mil dólares
ahorrados para que dispongan de ese
dinero cuando tenga cuando estén un
poquito más grandes y tal vez de una
edad en la que no quieran trabajar pero
qué pasa si nosotros decidimos hacer
esto no con cinco dólares sino con doce
dólares con 50 centavos llegan un millón
de dólares porque todos mis clientes me
dicen es quiero tener un millón de
dólares a instalas opción es súper fácil
es cuestión de tener un plan y ser
consecuentes con la ejecución de ese
plan no es nada difícil que me gusta de
esto y siempre lo desglosó bien en la
cantidad de inversión que se hace en
cada uno de las variables veamos el
millón de dólares nosotros invertimos
cuánto 182 mil dólares en 40 años
haciendo un ahorro de 12 dólares con 50
centavos diarios
y en intereses estamos ganando 817 mil
dólares
y saber trabajar con el dinero y eso es
aprovechar la gran variable del tiempo
si vemos el otro ejercicio de los 400
mil dólares estamos invirtiendo 73 mil y
estamos ganando en intereses 327 mil
dólares 5 dólares diarios es algo así
como 150 dólares mensuales al inicio tal
vez va a ser complicado luego les
garantizo que va a ser parte de sus
hábitos y ni siquiera se van a dar
cuenta que están constituyendo ese euro
y eso construye riqueza hay un concepto
muy poderoso en las finanzas personales
que me encanta utilizar y es el concepto
del factor café
este estudio se hizo en los eeuu hace
varios años en personas como las de su
edad y se descubrió que dado el su nivel
de ingreso y su nivel de gastos no se
podía estudiar y lo que se empezó a
hacer es investigar en qué estaban
gastando el dinero y se encontró que
personas como ustedes tendrían la
costumbre de generar gastos pequeños
a los que se les denominó el factor café
en este caso muy puntual y starbucks
comprar un café y una galleta eso más o
menos son ocho dólares en términos de lo
que nos cuesta y es la cantidad de
dinero que nosotros necesitamos utilizar
para construir bienestar financiero se
trata muchas veces de evaluar bien si lo
que tenemos que comprar es necesario o
no como les decía al inicio y a través
del mindfulness pasar del que
al por qué y finalmente llegar a él para
que que eso nos va a dar una gran visión
sobre cómo manejamos el dinero y por qué
les quiero hacer un contraste del tiempo
bien lo mismo si la persona empieza a
los 40 años
miren las grandes diferencias que se
producen en su riqueza en el eje del
escenario número b llegábamos un millón
de dólares es la misma fórmula es el
mismo ahorro lo que cambia aquí es la
decisión de empezar de empezar joven o
empezar un poco más grande
ahí está la diferencia miren
las cifras
contra 198 mil dólares
cuatrocientos mil contra 80 mil dólares
acaso eso es de importancia ok
básicamente quiero dejar con ustedes
esta fórmula es muy importante trabaja
en la piensa en la utilice la de su vida
personal la educación es fundamental el
ahorro es la base de la riqueza y
finalmente si utilizamos el tiempo a
nuestro favor encontramos el bienestar
financiero hay una única variable que
quiero introducir y es la gratitud
seamos gratos con todo lo que tenemos
con la vida con cualquier cosa que
podamos hacer si nosotros combinamos
esto les garantizo que el cielo no será
el límite y por eso esta es mi imagen de
bienestar financiero muchas gracias
dios